Hello again. Well, that was a bit of guesswork.
But I think you might have guessed the right answer.
We can do so by elimination.
If we remove the angled brackets, the all of this HTML tag is going to turn into regular text.
This will create a very different behavior in Mozilla,
and therefore we are probably not going to reach the code
which originally caused the failure.
The same goes for select.
If we remove the attributes--that is, name equals operating system
or multiple or size equals 7--then our input will still be a select tag
with no attributes at all,
and this will still trigger the original failure.
So, you see that in this big HTML input, only eight characters are relevant
for reproducing the problem.
This will certainly give us nice reward from the Mozilla developers.